So now that we built it ourselves, I am going to show you the easy way to do it, which is to use
the built-in Python type called the dictionary and what a dictionary is is really an implementation
of a hashtable. It is built-in to Python so it is much easier to use than defining our own hashtable.
So far we have seen two complex types in Python. We have seen the string type and we have seen the
list type. Now we are going to introduce the dictionary type. So there are many things that are
common between these three. There are other things that are different so to create a string
we could have a sequence of characters inside quotes. To create a list, we use the square bracket
and we could have a sequence of elements inside the square bracket and the elements
could be any type unlike a string where they had to be characters. So our string was a sequence of
characters. Our list was a list of any kind of value so a list of elements of any value. The dictionary
type we are going to create using the curly bracket and entries inside the dictionary are key-value
pairs so here I have created dictionary with two elements and each element the key is a string.
Here is the string hydrogen and the value associated with that element is a number. The keys
in the dictionary can be any immutable value so they do not need to be strings. They could be
numbers. They could be other things. The values can be any value so what a dictionary is
is a set of key-value pairs and the property that a dictionary will give us is like the hashtable
that we can look up a key and get the value associated with that key so one important
property of all types is whether they are immutable or mutable. We saw that the string was immutable.
That means once we create a string we cannot modify that string. It has the same value.
It always has. A list was mutable. We could change the values of elements in the list after we
create the list. We could append to the list adding new elements to it. The dictionary is also mutable.
So after we create a dictionary we could add new key-value pairs to it. We could change the value
of values associated with keys. We saw with strings - if s is a string then we could do s[i]
that will give us the i letter in string. With list, we can do something very similar. If p is a list,
we can do p[i] to get the i element of the list. With dictionaries, it is a little bit different.
The syntax is the same. We can do d[k]. With both strings and lists, these were numbers.
Here, the k is whatever the key value is so this is the key in the dictionary. What d[k] will give us
the value associated with that key in the dictionary. We will see some examples soon. We can also use
our indexing in assignments we saw with the list we could do this that would replace the value
of the i element of p with whatever we have here. With the string, we cannot do that. That produces
an error, and the reason we cannot do it is because strings are immutable so there is no way to
modify characters in the string. With the dictionary, we can and what the meaning of this is very
similar to the meaning of update in our hashtable so that is equivalent to update the value
the value associated with k to be v.